why the hell is the bitcoin price going
down bitcoin was at 66 then 69 000. now
it's dropped last night everyone thought
the world was ending what the hell is
going on why is that happening yeah a
lot of this stuff um you know when
you're thinking about bitcoin the
bitcoin market a lot of this stuff on
the shorter time frame is just driven by
the leverage dynamics a lot of the
derivative stuff um so even you know the
most bullish kind of macro environment
we all kind of uh you know know what's
happening with inflation right now um
you know the thesis of digital gold of
something that's absolutely scarce has
never been stronger but uh in the in the
shorter time frames you kind of get
dislocations where uh people get a
little too greedy and and you know
bitcoin takes the takes away of math
spain so you're gonna you're gonna see
those those over leveraged traders
you're gonna see them all get wiped out
and you're kind of seeing that uh you
saw that a little bit last night this
morning and it's completely natural
right it's you know the volatility is is
the price you pay for returns and
anybody that's over levered is is going
to get wiped out along the way and when
you see this happening do you get
excited or is this something that
worries you do you think it'll continue
to happen like walk me through just
what's going through your head as you're
watching this all occur in the short
term i mean i'm excited as a as a
bitcoin holder as a stacker i set some
limit orders at 60k that i was happy to
get filled so um you know that's just
you know looking at the market every day
when when kind of the traders are
levering up and price continues to sink
down a little bit i get excited because
i know that you know the the you know
strongest monetary asset in the world in
the history of the world is going to be
at a discount or most likely so you know
i i think in in terms of years and
decades uh you know less so in terms of
hours or days and so you know this this
sort of stuff you know blood in the
streets is something that excites me as
a bitcoin accumulator
i love it i i love that you have just as
much conviction as i do all right let's
get to these charts we got the aggregate
futures open interest uh and you've got
a piece that is circled here in pink
that says 26.4 billion dollars what what
are you looking at in this chart
yeah so you know this is basically what
we're talking about when we talk about
derivatives this is the open interest so
this is on both sides of the trade long
and short how much like money is is
directionally embedding on the price of
bitcoin uh in the derivatives market and
so this is you know recently over the
last couple days when we were at 67.68
we hit an all-time high there and some
people are saying you know that's pretty
bearish uh we're looking kind of like at
this double top in the market and and i
disagree for a couple reasons um in
dollar terms we were at an all-time high
but if you go to the next slide there
the the makeup of the derivatives market
is actually a lot different than it was
in april um we've been talking about
this brought it up i think on the last
couple of times but what you're looking
at is is the collateral that's being
used to enter these contracts is a lot
different so there's a lot less bitcoin
margin there's a lot less bitcoin
collateral that's that's in this futures
open interest which means that
essentially um you know there's less
likely to be these huge massive
drawdowns um as as traders get over
leveraged and and you know 68 to 60k is
not a massive drawdown we're talking
about the type of stuff we saw on you
know in in may or maybe march of 2020 um
just the makeup of the derivatives
markets a lot different for instance you
saw bitmex uh i think last week they
said hey we're we have a tethered
contract tyler open interest and so that
has about two billion dollars and bitmex
is you know kind of notoriously known as
this bitcoin only derivatives bucket
shop so just kind of the makeup of the
market is a lot different um and under
the surface when you're just looking at
the price you may not you may not see
that
so when you look at this specific chart
this percent open interest uh bitcoin
margin we see from let's call it march
april all the way through uh you know
now we continue to see that trending
down now we're at about 45
or so but you can see that the price is
overlaid and the price was tracking
pretty much until august and that's when
we saw the price uh shoot up what do you
think actually creates that divergence
like why was it tracking so well up
until august and then we get a
divergence between the pricing gray and
the uh kind of yellow or gold there in
that percent open interest of bitcoin
margin
yeah so i think during bull markets you
see just you know because of more of the
accumulation less of the derivatives you
see you see price really go parabolic
like we saw from say november of last
year through through april um and and
during that time you see a lot of
momentum traders just a lot of natural
greed and speculation in the market you
see traders looking to long their loans
looking to margin along bitcoin to get
more bitcoin um because you know the
thing's going up 500 percent um and so
we kind of all saw that get washed out
and so over the course of say
april may into the summer you saw all of
that like bitcoin margin all that
bitcoin collateral as the price drew
down 50 55 you saw all that get wiped
out uh and in the meantime kind of you
know behind the scenes you see this
continued like maturation and i would
say like maybe stable coin dollarization
of crypto markets um which you know some
people think is is bad you see a lot of
tether fud uh but this isn't just tether
it's tether usdc a lot of other staple
coin competitors um and in terms of you
know uh the maturation the
financialization of bitcoin um you know
this is this is really good this is
bullish um the more kind of stable coins
the more kind of integration with the
legacy system um and and rather just you
know instead of crypto collateral where
you kind of see these this huge
convexity and all these these downside
moves um that that's a good thing so
you're just you know you're continuing
to see the aggregate amount of stable
coins in this market continue to go up
um and i think that's a trend that you
know won't end any time soon so i kind
of expect this chart to continue to go
lower